monsieur girard bonjour aux jo beaucoup
de choses dans ce budget oui j'avais
présenté aujourd'hui mais il ya quand
même un chiffre qui retient mon
attention d'abord et avant tout c'est
cette croissance de 2% que vous prévoyez
pour 2020 nous savons qui a le
coronavirus ah oui plusieurs semaines
s'ajoute aussi la crise du pétrole
maintenant est-ce que ce budget tient
encore la route aujourd'hui même compte
tenu du ralentissement économique qu'on
attend maintenant définitivement
et lorsque nous avons fait le budget il
y avait les prévisions des économistes
et c'est vrai qu'à 2 % dans l'intervalle
des prévisions on est un peu élevé mais
la raison c'est que nous connaissions
l'impulsion qui allait venir du
gouvernement on a quand même une
croissance des dépenses de 5% et la
contribution gouvernementale à la
croissance est plus celui que ce que les
oeufs les prévisionnistes du secteur
privé avec se dit aujourd'hui les
économistes du secteur privé voilà
croissante du québec davantage autour de
1 que de 2%
ils vont vous manquez de l'argent tantôt
là effectivement les une révision il est
le québec il ya des stabilisateurs
automatiques le québec est un
importateur d'énergie
on a eu une baisse de taux d'intérêt et
on a une impulsion de la dépense
gouvernementale
alors ce qu'on observe c'est que les
prévisionnistes pour l'ensemble de
l'économie mondiale révise sur la sur
l'année 2020 à la braise un demi pour
cent et bien sûr les pâquis plus élevé
dans le premier six mois et les faits
d'autres c'est approximativement la
moitié pour le québec ça 10.25 donc
étant donné
l'incertitude qui persiste sur le
coronavirus la crise pétrolière y est à
peu près clair que vous allez devoir
intervenir davantage et donc annoncé
peut-être un des sites près le
versements au fonds des générations pas
avant nécessairement mai après le
versement au fonds des générations
mais c'est à dire que nous on intervient
immédiatement parce qu'on avait de la
marge de manoeuvre dans l'année fiscale
coup on va dépenser un milliard de plus
dans le mois de mars 2010 soit l'année
fiscale précédente
alors on accélère les dépenses pour
supporter l'économie dans l'année
précédente on a déjà prévu 5% de
croissance parce qu'on voyait les nuages
on voyait que l'économie mondiale
ralentit alors on va donner une
impulsion positive et c'est vrai
lorsqu'il ya toute une analyse de
sensibilité dans le budget c'est vrai
que si le pib est inférieur de 1 pour ça
les packs sur les finances publiques
serait approximativement d'un million 1
milliard oui un milliard de moins en
revenus pour vous c'est la chambre des
revenus des départs mais vous auriez
vous avez 14 milliards dans ce qu'on
appelle la réserve de stabilisation qui
vous permettrait donc de respecter la
loi sur l'équilibré budgétaire
exactement et c'est important de
mentionner que lorsqu'on prévoit
l'équilibré budgétaire en 2020 et 21 c
après contribution au fonds des
générations de 2.7 milliards et donc
nous avons surplus comptable de 2.7
milliards dont vous avez une marge de
manoeuvres exceptionnelles n'y a pas un
gouvernement au canada qui est votre
marge de manoeuvre je peux parler pour
nous pour le québec le québec ne jamais
été en position de force comme cela de
demain ralentissement économique nous
notre économie les fondements de notre
économie sont solides
nos finances publiques sont saines alors
on est en position pour aider les
québécois
si les entreprises les individus aux
besoins des nous serons le pot mais
structurellement vieillissement de la
population
nous vivons ça présentement là vous êtes
à 5 6% de croissance de dépasse par
année pour des revenus de peu près 3 %
d'augmentation en italie 2 à 3 % et 3 %
de revenus 5 des dépenses
c'est très facile à expliquer pourquoi
c'est parce que nous avons réduit le
fardeau fiscal des québécois et 10
entreprises alors ça ça diminue les
revenus et nous porte nous partons d'une
position de surplus alors pour
équilibrer il faut que les dépenses
croissent plus vite que les revenus
oui pour équilibrer donc on veut on
cherche l'équilibré budgétaire à
l'envers chercher l'équilibré budgétaire
afin d'avoir plus de revenus que de
dépenses ne vous êtes en train de dire
ça prend moins de revenus plus de
dépenses que rené lalique in on accélère
les dépenses parce que des besoins en
santé et en éducation
et puis cette année aussi avait des
personnes en situation de vulnérabilité
les femmes victimes de violences
conjugales un besoin de réinvestissement
au niveau de la protection de la
jeunesse au faisceau c'est des dépenses
qui sont nécessaires et ses dépenses
l'avons aidé l'économie parce que le
gouvernement a un rôle lorsque la
demande privée diminue de remplacer
celle ci de stimuler l'économie mais
structurellement si quelques années
l'institut du québec où la chair de
l'université de sherbrooke en finances
publiques vous dise structurellement la
situation va changer avec le
vieillissement de la population donc à
quel moment vous allez faire le virage
pour vous assurer que vos dépenses ne
galopent pas comme ça le vieillissement
la population s'est déjà commencé c'est
pas une révision est il autre chose
c'est que nous faisons tout ce qui est
possible pour améliorer le potentiel
économique du québec à long terme de
faire passer de ce qui était estimé par
le précédent gouvernement 1.3 pour st
nous on veut l'amener à 2%
il a mené 1 4 1 4 1 et suivants oui vous
avez raison mais ce qu'on l'éléphant
qu'on fait c'est sur le long terme on a
besoin de gains de productivité on a
besoin que la croissance à long terme du
québec se soit 2 % et non pour un
parcours dans le virage vert parce que
oui parler d'économie verte et des gens
ici qui vous disent vous inciter les
gens à utiliser du transport collectif
roulait vers rennes jusqu'en 2021 puis
ensuite on sait pas trop ce que ça va
donner
où les verts et financer
c'est à dire budget écrit jusqu'au 31
mars 2021 pour les verts existants mais
l'argent pour où les verts et là sur
l'ensemble du continent sa bosse
poursuivre ensuite avance poursuivre en
suis ok mais est ce que il ne faut pas
citer les jantes emprunter le transport
en commun puis à acheter des voitures
électriques ou s'apprend pas du malus
aussi dans le bonus malus parce que les
ventes d'automobiles augmente les ventes
de véhicules utilitaires sport augmente
cette vie que sur 10 et des véhicules
utilitaires ce pas oui on l'a fait
moi j'ai consulté beaucoup durant les
processus et et des consultations
prébudgétaires et les gens achètent ces
véhicules pourquoi sur la sécurité
alors tant que les mentalités changeront
pauvres que les gens tant qu on aura
cette perception que les véhicules et
une situation plus sécuritaire pour elle
ils vont demeurer populaire alors on
peut avoir de ces véhicules hoc sont
électriques hybrides
on doit les constructeurs doivent aussi
discuter ou répondre à cette
préoccupation du brut et des citoyens et
vous faites quoi parce que vous insistez
transport que l'aiguillé
mais est-ce que vous devez pas agir en
fonction de ce que plusieurs appellent
l'urgence climatique réseau reims tadic
et déjà des taxes sur l'essence la
bourse carbone se répercute sur la taxe
on n'était pas allé plus loin là dessus
mais c'est à dire que c'est la société
vont évoluer le plein 10 ans cette année
on n'a pas amené de taxation des v ux de
pénalisation pour les grosses cylindrées
ça peut pas dire que ce sera toujours
comme ça mais présentement les gens à
chaque ces véhicules là pour la sécurité
est ce qu'il y a urgence climatique pour
vous oui je pense que définitivement on
à l'évidence scientifique d'une part et
d'autre part on observe des événements
extrêmes plus fréquemment
est ce que la taxe scolaire va baisser
ça c'était déjà prévu ça va se
poursuivre le 1er juillet
le deuxième tiers de notre commerce est
ce que d'autres mesures pour les
contribuables prochainement
c'est quoi la prochaine étape la
prochaine étape
lorsque nous devions faire c'est on a
remis 12 milliards sur six ans parce
qu'on a bonifié la location famille on a
éliminé la contribution additionnelle on
ne le crédit d'impôt pour les
travailleurs d'expérience on a le crédit
d'impôt pour les proches aidants
alors la taxe scolaire alors ça c'était
nos promesses électorales nos
engagements nous les avons réalisé dans
le futur héros de budget il redoute mais
il ya d'autres mesures à venir
il a toujours eu d'autres budgets mais
ce que dire de réduction de charges
fiscales vous souhaitez davantage
aujourd'hui on parle du budget